canadian prime minister justin trudeau
is very concerned about freedom in
ukraine
western intelligence agencies believe
russia will invade ukraine any day now
and so trudeau has announced that he
will be giving ukraine a half billion
dollar loan and an additional 7.8
million dollars worth of military
equipment it is even possible that we
will see canadian soldiers fighting
alongside other nato allies in ukraine
to repel putin's invading force so
crucial is it to western civilization
that we maintain freedom
in ukraine and to prepare for this
robust defense of freedom in eastern
europe justin trudeau is making sure to
quash every last gasp of freedom in his
own country
in response to the peaceful convoy of
truckers protesting the government's
vaccine mandate trudeau has officially
suspended civil liberties in canada
federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades and
occupations it is now clear
that responsible leadership
requires us to do this
these measures must be and will be
compliant with our charter of rights and
freedoms indeed the emergencies act was
created in the late 80s to flow from and
uphold the charter
we'll always
defend the rights of canadians to
peaceful assembly and to freedom of
expression here in our capital city
families small businesses have been
enduring illegal obstruction of their
neighborhoods
occupying streets
harassing people breaking the law
this is not
a peaceful protest
blm riots that's mostly peaceful but
truckers honking to avoid injecting
themselves with an experimental drug of
dubious moral and medical value that
is terrorism this sort of law last
invoked by trudeau's father when he was
the leader of canada will allow the
suspension of public assembly travel and
the use of property it will allow the
government to force privately owned tow
truck companies to do the government's
bidding and take the trucks
it will even freeze and seize the
financial assets of the truckers and the
truckers supporters
first we are broadening the scope of
canada's anti-money
laundering and terrorist financing rules
so that they cover crowd funding
platforms
and the payment service providers they
use
these changes cover all forms of
transactions
including digital assets
such as crypto currencies
the illegal blockades have highlighted
the fact that crowdfunding platforms
and some of the payment service
providers they use
are not fully captured under the
proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing act
regular old truckers who don't want to
inject themselves needlessly with an
experimental drug are having their
rights their way of life and their
property taken from them in canada the
nicest smiliest most pleasant liberal
nation
on earth
and i'm supposed to be worried about a
territorial battle in one of the most
frequently conquered countries in the
history of the world
i don't want to sound callous
and i am sure vladimir putin is a no
good dirty rotten terrible guy
but how exactly are we supposed to
defend freedom on the other side of the
world when we can't even preserve it in
america's hat i'm glad you like that
clip ring the bell please
you will get the notifications if you
don't get the notifications subscribe
over at apple podcast spot if i stitch
your google play wherever you get your
audio podcasts type in
the michael null show subscribe leave a
five star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]